[Music]
today's question comes from jenna in
florida i'm starting college in the fall
and i have scholarships to pay about 70
of tuition
what do i do to make up the gap gonna be
a long summer jenna
i love this question
well of course you can still apply for
more scholarships that's the first and
easiest spot to kind of start going with
it you already have 70 which is great i
don't know if that's tuition
scholarships that are covered just
automatically because you went to a
certain school but i encourage you to
apply for outside scholarships
a lot of students don't realize that
when you get to college you can still
apply for scholarships they think you
know i passed high school this is it i
can't get scholarships but there are
tons of outside scholarships for people
who are in college who are in grad
school so definitely keep applying i
actually have a friend who didn't start
applying for scholarships until she was
in college and was able to still get
enough money to pay for tuition books
housing everything so even if you are
past high school what's the best place
for her to look for those well we like
scholarshipowl.com that's a great
database i recommend students use these
scholarship databases which are
basically search engines for
scholarships they specifically take your
information and find targeted
scholarships for you now we looked at i
had a lady asked me the same question
the other day and i told her we had
looked at several of these
databases and the problems with some of
them is the uh there there's kind of two
types of scholarships out there there's
ones that are legitimate but not
everybody knows they're there they're
kind of hard to find sometimes and then
other times there's somebody that's
basically trying to
they're fishing just to get your
information so they can try to sell you
something later you know what i'm
talking about absolutely how do you tell
the difference in those well it's
important to dig deeper into the company
find out is it a credible company what's
their heart and mission behind the
scholarship why are they giving away a
scholarship like do your research a lot
of people just find scholarships and
they automatically think you know i
should apply for the scholarship but one
of the most untime intensive parts of
applying for scholarships is actually
making sure you find the right
scholarship so take time to dig through
and see if these companies are legit and
see what they're all about and see what
the odds are of winning that scholarship
a lot of them are kind of sweepstakes
type scholarships you know so how how uh
is jenna gonna find time to do this
because i was getting retailer to work
80 hours a week this summer
that was next on my list of things to do
is work i mean we've actually found that
students who work part-time do better in
school than students who don't work at
all so it is important to have a job
even if you don't necessarily need the
money like jenna does you know still
work it can help you create that
discipline but if you do need the money
that's the way to go like pour into
getting a job and work strategically a
lot of companies offer tuition
assistance and tuition benefits so not
only can you get a paycheck but they may
actually pay for part of your tuition so
yes
target amazon starbucks several of them
are doing this yeah
yeah and they're off on all kinds of
scholarship options and or
tuition benefits while you work there
and you might even keep working there
while you're in school it won't hurt you
a bit but here's the thing okay
if you just really did work like three
jobs
and uh you try to solve a grown-up
problem with like a grown-up solution
no whining about i went my hammer off
you're like a grown-up and you're
dealing with a grown-up problem here
which is you want to go to school and
you don't have the money
and so sorry you're not 12.
uh welcome to the big leagues kiddo
uh get your butt in gear and go make
some money
work work work work work work work
there's a it's a surefire money making
scheme this work thing yeah and you know
go get that go get that
30 an hour babysit walk dogs i don't
care what you do adore dash i don't care
what you do but just work all the time
between now and the time you go to
school and you'll have the money yep
magical magical magical i was super
excited you won't have to understand it
because you'll be at work all the time
i talked to somebody at building wealth
and he had just received his bachelor's
in accounting and he's trying to figure
out how to pay for his master's degree
and we started brainstorming ideas
looking at second jobs and i recommended
that he talk to his employer to see if
they happen to have any tuition benefit
programs or a way that he could make up
the money and he just sent me a message
the other day on instagram saying that
he talked to his employer and they
offered him three to four
part-time assignments that were extra in
addition to his normal full-time job and
he's going to be able to completely
cover his master's degree right over
time yeah i mean he's got like
accounting type overtime that's not
that's not that's good money yep that's
a whole lot better than walking dogs i'm
saying that's great yeah suggestion and
good result so that's what you do boys
you get scholarships uh uh you pick a
school you can afford which i assume you
already have because you got 70 of it
covered
and um then we go to town making money
and finding free money and those are
your keys
that's the three main things and go
ahead and plan on working while you're
in school
a couple things happen
like christina said we found
student athletes and people who work
while they're in school tend to have
higher gpas
and they learn time management skills
because they don't have a lot of time
so they have to go to between work and
going to class you ain't got time to
play beer pong
so um it's an amazing thing and we we
see that happen over and over and over
again the other thing that
working students have a tendency to do
is graduate on time mm-hmm because
they're freaking one out
they're paying for it which is a huge
it's not like
we're gonna ride the lazy river you know
oh my god like if you want to save money
on college that's like a one make sure
you graduate in four years it's crazy
the statistics around how many students
do not graduate in four years and how
many students actually take six years or
longer i think it's like 40 take six
years or longer which when you think
about that two extra years that's so
much money so it's like barely that's
her parents fault they should have cut
them off
see i told mine they have four years
and you know have a plan there's a
little thing called a syllabus you just
work if you go to those classes for four
years you magically graduate it's
freaking amazing
follow the plan execute i mean and don't
tell me you got too much to do give me
give me a break i mean this is grown-up
stuff yeah this is grown-up stuff and so
we're solving a uh
a grown-up problem with a child's
mentality too often and that's how we
end up with two hundred thousand dollars
of student loan debt for a degree in
left-handed puppetry well and that's the
sad thing is a lot of times that
students taking out student loans to
cash flow this it's not just even parent
money and that's part of the reason why
we really got to clamp down on this
toxic industry that just allows students
to borrow money you know as much as they
want for years of college you know we
really got to get students to be more
disciplined and like you said follow the
syllabus and get gra get your degree in
time and just don't waste that extra
time and money now when uh senator
marcia blackburn was here the other day
you were on with me right yep and i
asked her on the air and said when are
we going to get rid of when are you
going to quit making student loans
before we start talking about forgiving
them
and she went
yeah that's a good idea
come on marsha you can do it you can do
it uh yeah you can't talk about
forgiving something because it's evil
and bad while you keep making it that's
intellectually dishonest
so we have to stop this ridiculous out
of control business
that is called congress oh my gosh so
good job 70 i'm proud of you you already
got a bunch of it covered jenna you got
the right stuff
so christina gave you the sweet answer
go get more scholarships i gave you the
old grandpa answer get your butt in gear
and go to work this is the ramsey show